I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi there. How are you? I am well. How is New York City? It is great. You know, I just love that we can do the podcast from two different cities. We're Bicostal Office, ladies. So cool. I've got my sound engineer here, Casey, and we are
我是珍娜·费舍。而我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们还是好朋友。现在我们专门为你带来《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当时身在其中的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。哈啰。嗨。你好吗？我很好。纽约市怎么样？非常棒。你知道的，我特别喜欢我们能从两个不同的城市录制播客。我们是跨海岸的《办公室女士》。太酷了。我的音响工程师凯西也在，我们
ready to go. I cannot believe we're on the second to last episode of Season 6. Me either. It's crazy. It's crazy. This is The Chump. It is Season 6, Episode 25, written by Aaron Scherr and directed by Randall Einhorn. Give us a summary, Jenna. Okay. Since you asked. Here's your summary. Last week, Michael learned that Donna, the woman he's been seeing, is married and is cheating on her husband with Michael. But Michael does not call off the relationship. And he receives a lot of flak from his employees for continuing his affair with Donna. Meanwhile, Pam and Jim struggle to stay awake at work after a late night with the baby and Dwight and
准备好了。真不敢相信我们已经到了第六季倒数第二集。我也是。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。这一集叫《笨蛋》。这是第六季第二集，由亚伦·舒尔编剧，兰德尔·艾因霍恩导演。珍娜，给我们总结一下。好的。既然你问了。这是你的总结。上周，迈克尔得知他一直在交往的女性唐娜其实已婚，并且背着丈夫和迈克尔偷情。但迈克尔并没有终止这段关系。而且因为继续和唐娜有染，他受到了员工们的百般非难。与此同时，帕姆和吉姆因为和宝宝熬夜到很晚，在工作时努力强打精神；而德怀特和
Angela are at odds over the validity of their co-parenting contract. Oh, I have some good stuff about the Dwight and Angela co-parenting contract. I'll wait till we get to it. I was hoping you would, lady, because I think there's stories there. Mm-hmm. All right. Fast fact number one, this was our 125th episode of The Office. Wow. Yeah. We shot this episode the week of March 19th, 2010, and it was viewed by 6.6 million people. That seems like a lot of folks. It was a lot of folks. We were second in the ratings right behind Grey's Anatomy. They were a big competition at this time. I mean, it was a big deal if you were even holding your
安吉拉则因为他们的共同抚养协议是否合法而争执不下。哦，我有一些关于德怀特和安吉拉共同抚养协议的精彩内容。我等我们聊到那儿再说。我正希望你这么说呢，女士，因为我觉得那里有很多故事。嗯哼。好吧。幕后快讯第一条，这是我们《办公室》的第125集。哇。是的。我们拍摄这一集的周是2010年3月19日那周，有660万观众收看。这听起来像是有很多人。确实有很多人。我们在收视率上排名第二，紧随《实习医生格蕾》之后。那时候他们可是个强大的竞争对手。我的意思是，哪怕能跟《实习医生格蕾》
own with Grey's Anatomy. I know. I mean, they were always number one. Now, the reviews for this episode were pretty good. The AV Club gave it a B plus, and it ranked as the 10th most well-liked episode by fans for season six on Office Tally. So, of all 26 episodes in season six, this was ranked 10th. It was very well-liked. I love a stat. Oh, me too, lady. Now, the fan-favorite moment that was most mentioned in the comments was from this episode. There was a moment. Oh, I'm going to guess I'm Beyonce always. Oh, yes. That did get a lot of mentions. That was very popular. That's my favorite line. That's a mug right there. Yeah. No,
平分秋色都是一件了不起的大事。我知道。我的意思是，他们总是排名第一。关于这一集的评价相当不错。影音俱乐部（The AV Club）给出了B+的评价，在Office Tally网站上，它被粉丝们评为第六季第十受欢迎的剧集。所以，在第六季的全部26集中，它排在第十位。它非常受欢迎。我很喜欢统计数据。哦，我也是，女士。现在，评论中被提及最多的粉丝最爱时刻就来自这一集。有一个时刻。哦，我猜我永远是碧昂丝。哦，是的。那个确实获得了很高的提及率。那个非常受欢迎。那是我的最爱台词。那简直能印在马克杯上。对。不，
the most popular moment was when Dwight and Angela are having sex in the warehouse, and it pans up to Pam and Jim listening from their sleeping spot. Oh, that's hilarious. All right. Fastback number two is a location breakdown. We got a fan question from Harmjen V in the Netherlands. Where did you film the baseball game, and who were the players? Good question. Yeah. I mean, a big portion of this episode takes place at a baseball field with Michael and Andy watching Donna's husband, who is a high school baseball coach. This was our first day of shooting. We filmed on location at College of the Canyons on Rockwell
最受欢迎的时刻是德怀特和安吉拉在仓库里亲热，然后镜头摇上去，拍到帕姆和吉姆在他们睡觉的地方偷听。哦，太搞笑了。好吧，幕后快讯第二条是一个外景分析。我们收到了来自荷兰的哈姆延·V的粉丝提问。你们在哪里拍摄的棒球比赛，球员都是谁？好问题。对。我的意思是，这一集很大一部分内容发生在棒球场，迈克尔和安迪看着唐娜的丈夫，他是一名高中棒球教练。这是我们拍摄的第一天。我们在加利福尼亚州圣塔克拉利塔的洛克韦尔
Canyon Road in Santa Clarita, California. And then our base camp, which is where they put all the trailers and they put the food and hair and makeup, everything. Yes. That was in an adjacent parking lot. It was parking lot number eight. So if you're a diehard fan and you even want to tour our base camps, you can go to College of the Canyons parking lot eight. And that is where Steve Carell and Ed Helms had their lunch that day. So everyone you see in these scenes are background performers. Randy Cordray told me we had around a hundred extras that day for the baseball scenes. Yeah. For the baseball scenes. He said that they
峡谷路上的峡谷学院进行了外景拍摄。然后我们的基地，也就是他们放置所有房车、提供食物、发型和化妆等所有东西的地方。是的。那是在一个相邻的停车场。那是8号停车场。所以，如果你是一个死忠粉，甚至想参观我们的基地，你可以去峡谷学院的8号停车场。那正是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔和艾德·海尔姆斯那天吃午餐的地方。所以你在这些场景中看到的所有人都是背景演员。兰迪·科德雷告诉我，那天拍摄棒球场景时，我们大约有一百名群众演员。是的。为了拍摄棒球场景。他说他们
went to Central Casting. You know Central Casting. That's the famous background casting agency. I was signed up with them when I first came to Ellen. I was signed up with them. You know my 90210 story. Oh yes. Yeah. Exactly. Well, Central Casting provided us with all of the spectators and here is what we asked for. We wanted six people who could be grandparents. We wanted 18 adults to be parents and we needed 34 high school students but all of the students had to be 18 years of age or older who looked younger because then they could work adult hours. Right. But for the actual baseball scene like the baseball players we used a different
去了中央选角公司。你知道中央选角公司。那是著名的背景演员选角机构。我刚来洛杉矶时就在他们那儿登记过。我也在他们那儿登记过。你知道我的《飞越比弗利》（90210）的故事。哦，是的。没错。好吧，中央选角公司为我们提供了所有的观众，以下是我们的要求。我们需要六位可以扮演祖父母的人，我们需要18位成年人扮演父母，我们还需要34名高中生，但所有学生必须年满18岁或以上，只是长得显年轻，因为这样他们就可以按照成年人的工时工作。对。但对于实际的棒球场景，比如棒球运动员，我们用了另一家
company. I guess it's no longer in business but it's called Smitty's Casting. Like Smitty with a Z. Smitty's Casting. And they were really playing. Yeah. The players were really playing and that's why we went to this casting place because they're a specialty casting service that provides productions with sports playing background performers. So we got enough people to fill two baseball teams. The Scranton Cole Hawks and the Wolverines. Smitty's Casting sent us two male umpires, one male assistant coach, three male Wolverines coaches, 18 male Cole Hawk players and 18 male Wolverine players.
公司。我想它已经不营业了，叫做史密斯选角公司。就像带有Z的史密斯。史密斯选角公司。他们是真的在打。对。球员们是真的在打，这就是为什么我们找这家选角公司，因为他们是一家专业选角服务机构，为影视制作提供擅长体育运动的背景演员。所以我们找到了足够的人来组成两支棒球队。斯克兰顿煤鹰队和金刚狼队。史密斯选角公司给我们派了两名男性裁判，一名男性助理教练，三名男性金刚狼队教练，18名男性煤鹰队球员和18名男性金刚狼队球员。
And then our wardrobe department provided the team uniforms. I would have signed up for Smitty's. Maybe they would have taken me as a tennis player. Yes. Exactly. Can you play at like an almost professional level? Well I um no I can't but you know what I have a very good forehand. I think maybe you would just put that on your profile over at Central Casting. I'm sorry to say I'm not sure you qualify for Smitty's. Thank you for calling. I don't make the Smitty's cut. I'm so sorry. We are looking for professional level sports players. Wow. Did you ever play on a college team or at the state level? No Jenna but I did. I'm sorry I'm not Jenna.
然后我们的服装部门提供了球队制服。我本该在史密斯选角公司登记的。也许他们会把我当成网球运动员收下。没错。你的水平能达到接近专业级别吗？好吧，我……不，我不能，但你知道吗，我的正手打得非常好。我想也许你只需把这写进你在中央选角公司的个人资料里。我很遗憾地通知你，我不确定你符合史密斯的资格。谢谢来电。我没有达到史密斯的标准。非常抱歉。我们在寻找专业级别的运动员。哇。你曾在大学球队或州级别比赛过吗？没有，珍娜，但我……对不起，我不是珍娜。
I'm the woman on the phone at Smitty's. No Barbara at Smitty's. Here's the thing. I was once told by my high school coach that I have a lovely country club game. So ma'am I'm so sorry. I'm gonna have to just forward you over to Central Casting but congratulations on your terrific forehand. I hear some snark with Barbara. Well you've kept Barbara on the phone for a very long time. She needs to move on to other calls that are actually going to produce a client. Oh my gosh. Barbara at Smitty's. Listen. That's. Try being Barbara. Okay. Not easy. It's not easy to be Barbara. Thank you for calling Smitty's. This is Barbara. Hey um so I would like to sign up for
我是史密斯选角公司接电话的那位女士。不，我是史密斯的芭芭拉。事情是这样的。我以前听我高中教练说过，我的乡村俱乐部球局打得很优雅。所以，女士，非常抱歉。我得把你转接到中央选角公司了，不过祝贺你拥有极棒的正手。我听出了芭芭拉语气中的讽刺。好吧，你跟芭芭拉通了很长时间电话。她得去处理其他能真正带来客户的电话了。哦天哪。史密斯的芭芭拉。听着。这。试着当一次芭芭拉。好吧。不容易。当芭芭拉可不容易。谢谢致电史密斯选角公司。我是芭芭拉。嘿，嗯……我想在史密斯
Smitty's. I play pool and also I can bowl very well. Are you professional level? How do you define professional? Clicking. Look at the sass when you're Barbara. Do you see what I'm saying? Look what you have to deal with. All right. Okay. Should we move on to FastFact number three? Let's do it. I'm calling FastFact number three. Is there a guest star in the house? Yes there is. We have three new guest stars in this episode and guess what? They have all appeared on the TV show House. Oh. That's why there's a guest star in the house. Oh. You're making a pun. I'd punt it. You punt it. So Amy Pete's is back as Donna but this FastFact refers to our never-before-seen guest stars. For example Bruno Oliver as our mediator
选角公司登记。我打台球，而且保龄球也打得很好。你是专业级别的吗？你怎么定义专业？点击声。看看你当芭芭拉时的那股傲慢劲儿。你看到我说的是什么了吗？看看你得应付些什么。好吧。好。我们该进入幕后快讯第三条了吗？开始吧。我来宣布幕后快讯第三条。有客串明星驾到吗？是的，确实有。我们在这一集里有三位新客串明星，你猜怎么着？他们都出演过电视剧《豪斯医生》（House）。哦。这就是为什么有客串明星在“豪斯（House）”里。哦。你在开双关语玩笑。我接住这个梗了。你接住了。所以艾米·皮茨回归饰演唐娜，但这条快讯指的是我们从未见过的客串明星。例如，布鲁诺·奥利弗饰演我们的调解员
Mr. Barr. He has been on a rest of development, Mad Men, Modern Family, most recently in the movie Birds of Prey and House. Bruno was so much fun and he was just amazing. Like I loved all of our scenes. As an actor I have to imagine that was such a fun guest star to come on the show and work with you and rain in those scenes. He was so good too. It's just the voice of reason between these two absolutely ridiculous people. He had some of my favorite lines. So our other guest star is Donna's husband Shane who was played by Larkin Campbell. Shane has appeared in Passions 24, Criminal Minds, Grey's Anatomy, our big competition and also House. Finally our guest star Tina Huang who played the reporter at the end who
巴尔先生。他曾出演过《发展受阻》、《广告狂人》、《摩登家庭》，最近还在电影《猛禽小队》和《豪斯医生》中出演过。布鲁诺太有趣了，他简直棒极了。就像我喜欢我们所有的对手戏一样。作为一名演员，我得想象有这样一个有趣的客串明星来到剧组，和你一起合作并掌控那些场景，一定很有趣。他也很棒。他简直就是这两个绝对荒谬的人之间的理性声音。他有一些我最喜欢的台词。所以我们的另一位客串明星是唐娜的丈夫谢恩，由拉金·坎贝尔饰演。谢恩曾出演过《激情密码24》、《犯罪心理》、《实习医生格蕾》（我们的强劲对手）以及《豪斯医生》。最后，饰演在最后
confronts Michael about the exploding printers. She was a regular on the TV show Arrow. She also had a recurring role on Law and Order LA that was a short-lived spinoff of the Law and Order series. But I kid you not, she has also appeared on House. So there were guest stars in the House. Nice. Well, that's all I got for Fast Facts. But I was very tickled when I was looking up all of the actors' resumes and they had all been in House. Different seasons. Were you tickled by the fact that they had this crossover show or that you saw an opportunity to make a pun? Both, lady. Well, let's take a break because when we come back, we're going to find a whole bunch of radon kits all over the office. Or are
质问迈克尔关于爆炸打印机的记者的客串明星蒂娜·黄。她是电视剧《绿箭侠》的常驻演员。她还在《法律与秩序：洛杉矶》（Law and Order LA，那是《法律与秩序》系列一个短命的衍生剧）中饰演过常驻角色。但我没骗你，她也出演过《豪斯医生》。所以有客串明星在“豪斯”里。太好了。好吧，这就是我收集的幕后快讯。但当我查阅所有演员的简历，发现他们都演过《豪斯医生》时，我感到非常开心。不同的季度。你是为他们有这种交叉剧集而感到开心，还是因为你找到了一个讲双关笑话的机会？两个都有，女士。好吧，我们休息一下，因为当我们回来时，我们会发现办公室到处都是氡气检测盒。还是
they ant traps? Or are they the little thing you turn upside down and it goes moo? Or are they none of the above? We'll be back. I think this might be Toby's happiest day. A hundred percent. Well, it starts as Toby's happiest day. Yes, absolutely. It starts that way. He's in the conference room. You guys, he is holding court about one of his favorite subjects, radon. He is explaining to everyone that he'll be placing radon kits all over the office and he urges everyone, in particular Michael, and he's snapping at Michael to please not throw them in the garbage. At 13 seconds after Toby is snapping at Michael repeatedly, I want you to look at Steve's face as Michael.
说它们是蚂蚁陷阱？还是说它们是那种倒过来会发出“哞”声的小东西？或者以上都不是？我们马上回来。我觉得这可能是托比最开心的一天。百分之百。好吧，这确实是以托比最开心的一天开始的。是的，绝对的。它是以那样的情景开始的。他在会议室里。各位，他在高谈阔论他最喜欢的主题之一：氡气。他向大家解释说，他将在办公室各处放置氡气检测盒，并且敦促大家，特别是迈克尔——他冲着迈克尔厉声说道——请千万不要把它们扔进垃圾桶。在托比冲着迈克尔厉声说话13秒后，我希望你们看看史蒂夫扮演的迈克尔的脸。
The way he glares at Toby, I went back and looked in the script. You know, this was in the cold open shooting draft for secretary's day. I had to know if this look to Toby was scripted. It was. It said, Michael gives Toby an annoyed look and I want you to know, Jenna, we could not get through it. The first time Steve did it, we all erupted in the laughter. It's in the bloopers. Well, we got a fan question. Actually, a fan mail flurry asking, where is Pam during this cold open? Was Jenna not available for filming? Why am I not there? When I watched this cold open, I actually thought the same thing. And then I remembered, like you said, this cold open was written for secretary's day. We actually shot it that
他瞪着托比的那个神情，我回去查了剧本。你知道的，这是为秘书节拍摄的冷场开场定稿。我必须知道这个看着托比的表情是不是剧本里写好的。是的。上面写着：迈克尔给了托比一个恼怒的眼神，我想让你们知道，珍娜，我们简直拍不下去。史蒂夫第一次做这个表情的时候，我们所有人都爆笑出神了。这在搞笑花絮里。好吧，我们收到了一个粉丝提问。实际上是一阵粉丝来信的狂轰滥炸，问：这个冷场开场里帕姆在哪里？难道珍娜没空拍摄吗？为什么我不在那儿？当我观看这个冷场开场时，我其实也有同感。然后我想起来，就像你说的，这个冷场开场是为秘书节写的。我们实际上是在那一周拍摄的，当时帕姆的产假还没结束。
week and Pam was not back from her maternity leave yet. She returns after the cold open. So that's why I'm not there. And that's why I did not get to see Steve's glare. Oh, yeah, that's right. Pam is on maternity leave. Mm hmm. Well, that's a great catch. Michael is going to have this talking head. And he is going to walk around his office and talk about all of the radon test kits. The first radon kit he mistook for an ant trap. Then of course, he thought it was the thing that you turn over that makes the cow noise. And he just keeps tossing him in the trash. The last one he tossed in the trash just out of spite. Well, I asked Randy about these test kits and it turns out these are not real radon
她在冷场开场之后才回归。所以这就是我不在场的原因。这也是为什么我没能看到史蒂夫的那个瞪眼。哦，对，没错。帕姆在休产假。嗯哼。好吧，真是个绝佳的发现。迈克尔将有一段单人访谈。他要在办公室里走来走去，谈论所有的氡气测试盒。第一个氡气测试盒被他误当作了蚂蚁陷阱。然后当然，他以为那是那种翻过来就会发出牛叫声的东西。而他一直把它们往垃圾桶里扔。最后一个被他顺手扔进垃圾桶纯粹是出于恶意。好吧，我向兰迪询问了这些测试盒，结果证明这些并不是真正的氡气
test kits. Fakie test kit alert. Fakie radon test kit. Yeah, Randy said that the real ones at the time were actually pretty large and quite pricey. And we were looking for something smaller that really did kind of look more like an ant trap. So Phil Shea bought some inexpensive just electronic modules at Fry's Electronics for Toby to place around the office. And after we got them, we realized that they looked like the thing that goes moo. So that line was added later after our purchase was made. I was curious about that because it's so specific. And you know, it's an instant memory we all have. We've all seen those things. For sure. Angela, we got a piece of mail from Brent M. in Vancouver, Canada, who said, I
测试盒。假测试盒警报。假氡气测试盒。是的，兰迪说当时的真品其实相当大而且价格不菲。而我们在寻找一种更小、确实看起来更像蚂蚁陷阱的东西。所以菲尔·谢伊在弗莱电子（Fry's Electronics）买了一些便宜的电子模块，让托比放在办公室各处。在我们拿到它们之后，我们意识到它们看起来就像那个会发出“哞”声的东西。所以那句台词是在我们采购完成后才添加进去的。我对这一点很好奇，因为它是如此具体。而且你知道，这是我们所有人都有的即时记忆。我们都见过那些东西。确实如此。安吉拉，我们收到了来自加拿大温哥华的布伦特·M的一封信，他说：“我
was wondering if you ladies knew anything about the radon gas fan theory. I didn't. I don't. The radon gas theory basically suggests that everyone in the office is slowly getting poisoned by radon. One of the side effects of radon poisoning is odd behavior, which may explain the character's wacky behaviors in the later seasons. So you can go to the Reddit fan theories thread and you can read all about why the Scranton employees became so crazy in later seasons. And the theory is that we are reacting to the radon gas and that Toby was right. How many theories are there on this thread? Well, here was my thought about this theory is that it's kind of at odds with Toby being the Scranton strangler. I mean, wouldn't Toby
想知道各位女士知不知道关于氡气风扇的理论。我不知道。我也不知道。氡气理论基本上认为办公室里的每个人都在被氡气慢慢毒害。氡气中毒的副作用之一就是怪异的行为，这也许可以解释角色们在后几季中的古怪行为。所以你可以去 Reddit 的粉丝理论串，了解所有关于为什么斯克兰顿员工在后几季变得如此疯狂的原因。这个理论是说我们在对氡气做出反应，托比是对的。这个讨论串里有多少种理论呢？嗯，我关于这个理论的想法是，它和托比是斯克兰顿勒死魔这一设定有点冲突。我的意思是，难道托比不希望
want us to all die slowly from radon poisoning if he's the Scranton strangler? I mean, it would be like he's slowly strangling us all to death. I mean, it's the slow play. Yeah. I mean, or maybe he's just what trying to throw us off with his theatrics. Like he's pretending to care about radon, but he really is just going to strangle us all later. I don't know. It's making Toby really complex, if that's the case. It's true. Very complex killer. Well, Toby is going to say something that Michael cannot resist. He says that radon gas is silent but deadly. Silent but deadly. I mean, here comes Michael and fart noises. It's going to happen. I know. I mean, what did Toby expect? The group must be pretty
我们所有人都因为氡气中毒而慢慢死去吗，如果他是斯克兰顿勒死魔的话？我的意思是，这就好像他在慢慢勒死我们所有人致死。我的意思是，这是一个慢动作的阴谋。是的。我的意思是，或者也许他只是想用他的戏剧化行为来转移我们的视线？就像他假装关心氡气，但实际上他只是打算稍后勒死我们所有人。我不知道。如果是这样的话，这让托比变得非常复杂。确实如此。一个非常复杂的杀手。好吧，托比说了一句迈克尔无法抗拒的话。他说氡气是无声但致命的。无声但致命。我的意思是，迈克尔和放屁的声音要来了。这肯定会发生。我知道。我的意思是，托比期望什么呢？大家一定对托比
bored by Toby because they're actually finding Michael's joke hilarious. Yes, until he goes too far. Yeah. Yeah, he declares that if he had a gun with two bullets and he was stuck in a room with Hitler, bin Laden and Toby, he would shoot Toby twice. Then everyone's like Michael. Michael, Michael. No. And then of course Dwight has to be Dwight and say that he could get all three with one bullet and then he makes everyone line up to demonstrate. And that's how the conference room meeting ends. Yes, exactly. Well, I have a little something about this cold open. What's that? You know, it was in secretary's day. We often moved our cold opens around. So here is what was in the actual shooting draft for this
感到挺无聊的，因为他们实际上觉得迈克尔的笑话滑稽极了。是的，直到他太过分了。是的。是的，他宣称如果他有一把枪，里面有两颗子弹，而且他和一个房间里的希特勒、本·拉登以及托比在一起，他会朝托比开两枪。然后每个人都说，迈克尔。迈克尔，迈克尔。不。然后德怀特当然要扮演德怀特，说他用一颗子弹就能把这三个人全干掉，然后他让大家排成一队来演示。会议室的会议就是这样结束的。是的，完全正确。好吧，我关于这个开场白有一点要说。是什么？你知道，那是秘书节。我们经常调整开场白的位置。所以这是这个
episode. The cold open featured Dwight and he shares that he has one year's worth of provisions that can carry him through the chaotic first year of an apocalypse before cannibalism becomes accepted practice. After that, he'll be on Easy Street. But his provisions have a shelf life, so it's time to start eating and replacing everything that's about to expire. Then there's all this b-roll of Dwight eating smelly foods that have been stored for years. A jar of pickled okra, mackerel, the bullpen is grossed out and Jim in particular gives Dwight a lot of grief. Did we shoot that? We did. I have a memory of it. We did and there is a really funny blooper on this season six last DVD where you guys are all
剧集实际拍摄剧本里的内容。开场白以德怀特为主角，他分享说他有一年的物资储备，可以在乱世的荒原第一年支撑他度过，直到食人行为成为普遍接受的做法。在那之后，他就过上好日子了。但他的物资是有保质期的，所以是时候开始吃掉并更换所有快要过期的东西了。然后是一堆德怀特的B卷画面，他在吃那些存放多年的气味难闻的食物。一罐腌秋葵、鲭鱼，办公区的人都觉得恶心，尤其是吉姆，给德怀特找了不少麻烦。我们拍那个了吗？我们拍了。我有这段记忆。我们拍了，而且在第六季最后的 DVD 上有一个非常有趣的NG镜头，里面你们都在
in the break room and Dwight is eating gross stuff and he's going around and telling everyone how they would fare in this sort of zombie apocalypse. And Creed says, what would I do? And Dwight said, your skull would be used as a bowl. And Creed says, cool. You guys couldn't get through it. Rain, John, they would disintegrate. Every time Creed was like, what would I do? Every single time Creed said his line. Oh, that's amazing. Well, this episode opens with Aaron and Pam working together to unpack some shopping bags filled with ice cream that is named after songs by the Eagles. Yes, I loved the names of these ice creams. I kind of have a thing, Jenna, for ice cream flavors with fun names or crazy ice cream flavors.
休息室里，德怀特在吃恶心的东西，他到处走动，告诉每个人他们会在这种僵尸末日中过得怎么样。克里德说，我该怎么办？德怀特说，你的头骨会被当成碗用。克里德说，酷。你们简直拍不下去。雷恩，约翰，他们都崩溃了。每次克里德说“我该怎么办？”的时候。克里德每一次都说他的台词。哦，太棒了。好吧，这一集从艾琳和潘妮一起打开购物袋开始，里面装着以老鹰乐队歌曲命名的冰激凌。是的，我超爱这些冰激凌的名字。珍娜，我对名字有趣或者疯狂的冰激凌口味有点情结。
I just get so tickled by it. Oh my gosh, you are the marketing person's dream consumer. I know. I will buy ice cream just if it has a fun name. So Aaron explains that the Eagles are doing a theme ice cream in honor of the Eagles turning 60, the band, the Eagles, and the flavors are Desperado, witchy, womanila. And then later we find out cake it to the limit. I had to know what were some of the craziest ice cream flavors out there. And according to the website, Taste of Home, here are just a few that caught my eye. All right. So Sam, Cassie, Casey, let me know if you guys would try any of these. First one, Kraft macaroni and cheese ice cream from VanLuin Ice Cream. It has cream, milk, cane sugar,
我总是被它逗得乐不可支。哦天哪，你简直是营销人员梦寐以求的消费者。我知道。我买冰激凌仅仅是因为它有一个有趣的名字。所以艾琳解释说，老鹰乐队为了庆祝乐队成立 60 周年推出了主题冰激凌，乐队，老鹰乐队，口味有“亡命徒”（Desperado）、“邪恶女郎香草”（witchy, womanila）。然后后来我们发现还有“把这发挥到极致”（cake it to the limit）。我必须知道外面有哪些最疯狂的冰激凌口味。根据“家的味道”网站，以下是我注意到的一些口味。好吧。那么萨姆、卡西、凯西，让我知道你们是否会尝试其中任何一个。第一个，范鲁因冰激凌公司的卡夫通心粉和奶酪冰激凌。它有奶油、牛奶、蔗糖、
egg yolks, and of course, tons of Kraft cheese powder. You can find it in Brooklyn, New York and also nationwide. Lady VanLuin's made a grape-oupon ice cream that was just released recently and I thought of you. Oh my gosh. I would not eat that is the answer. That's a lactose intolerant nightmare. I would, yes. You would eat the Kraft mac and cheese ice cream. Okay. Moving on, Cheetos Flaming Hot Ice Cream from Marble Slab Creamery. No. Listen. It's got flaming hot. I won't eat a flaming hot Cheeto. Why would I want it in my ice cream? It's got this sweet cream base with flaming hot Cheetos crushed. Oh my gosh. You can get it also in a milkshake. You can find it in Texas and Southeast states. No. I mean,
蛋黄，当然还有大量的卡夫奶酪粉。你可以在纽约布鲁克林以及全国各地买到它。范鲁因女士最近刚推出了一款灰庞芥末（grey poupon）冰激凌，我当时就想到了你。哦天哪。我的回答是，我不会吃那个。那简直是乳糖不耐受者的噩梦。我会的，是的。你会吃卡夫通心粉和奶酪冰激凌。好吧。继续，大理石板奶油店的奇多火辣冰激凌。不。听着。它有火辣味。我连火辣奇多都不吃。我为什么要在冰激凌里吃它？它是甜奶油底座加上敲碎的火辣奇多。哦天哪。你也可以买到奶昔版本的。你可以在德克萨斯州和东南部各州找到它。不。我的意思是，
I'm going to say yes, but I'm not proud of myself. You guys, I'm getting sick. I'm getting sick. I don't feel well. Sam is too. Oh, well then get ready for this one. Thanksgiving dinner from the ice cream store in Delaware is composed of egg yolk vanilla ice cream studded with tomatoes, potatoes and green beans. This seasonal specialty is topped off with hot sauce and granulated sugar. Thanksgiving dinner. What do you think? I mean, you only live once. Oh my God. Casey. Casey. I think it might just be an engineer thing. Oh my gosh. Wait. I have two more. Hold on. I have a caveat. Can I lay down after? Yes. Sure. You would have to. If I can nap afterwards, yes. You can wear sweatpants and lay down. Then yes.
我要说我会，但我对此并不感到骄傲。伙计们，我要吐了。我要吐了。我感觉很不舒服。萨姆也是。哦，那你们准备好迎接这个吧。特拉华州冰激凌店的感恩节晚餐，由蛋黄香草冰激凌制成，里面布满了西红柿、土豆和青豆。这款季节限定特供上面浇了辣酱和白砂糖。感恩节晚餐。你们怎么看？我的意思是，人生苦短。哦天哪。凯西。凯西。我觉得这可能只是工程师的怪癖。哦天哪。等等。我还有两个。等一下。我有个附加条件。我之后可以躺一会儿吗？可以。当然。你得这样。如果我能在之后小睡一会儿，可以。你可以穿运动裤然后躺下。那可以。
Okay. Two last ones that caught my eye. Dill Pickle from Dakota Drug Company in Stanley, North Dakota. It's got a soft chestnut color that looks like caramel or peanut butter. This brine spike scoop is sure to surprise. I would try that just because it's one weird thing. I don't think I would do that one. Oh my gosh. I'd be afraid it would ruin Pickles for me. No, actually. And I know it's an audio podcast so you can't see, but Jenna is contemplating hard. No, I'm just, I'm not speaking because my stomach is hurting. Oh my God. Okay. I'll quickly do the last one, Jenna. Lobster from Ben and Bill's Chocolate Emporium. What is happening? You guys just let the food be the food. It's delicious as it was made in its
好吧。最后两个引起我注意的。北达科他州斯坦利达科他药公司的莳萝泡菜。它有一种柔和的栗色，看起来像焦糖或花生酱。这个盐水加料勺肯定会让人大吃一惊。我愿意尝试一下，仅仅因为它是一种奇怪的东西。我觉得我不会选那个。哦天哪。我怕它会毁了我对泡菜的喜爱。不，其实。我知道这是个音频播客，所以你们看不见，但珍娜在深思熟虑。不，我只是，我没说话是因为我胃疼。哦天哪。好吧。我快点说完最后一个，珍娜。本和比尔巧克力店的龙虾。这到底是怎么回事？你们就让食物保持食物本来的样子吧。它像原本做出来的那样
original form. It doesn't need to be turned into a dessert. That one is in Falmouth, Massachusetts. Casey, how did you know that? Have you had it? I've been, I've been to that place many times. Have you eaten it? I have tried it. Oh my God. How is it? It's weird. Does it taste like lobster? It tastes lobster-y. Yeah. Does it, is it like buttery lobster-y? It's a little bit buttery. I would say more, more of the, more of the kind of crabby aspect comes through. Well, you want to know why? Here are the ingredients. It's vanilla bean and butter-based lobster that has been cooked and chopped. Do you get the bib? I don't know. If so, then yes. I don't know. Anyway, I took us on a tangent there because I find these ice cream flavors so fascinating. Well, I'll tell you this.
原汁原味就很美味。它不需要变成甜点。那家店在马萨诸塞州法尔茅斯。凯西，你怎么知道的？你吃过吗？我去过，我去过那地方很多次。你吃过吗？我尝过。哦天哪。味道怎么样？很奇怪。它吃起来像龙虾吗？吃起来有龙虾味。是的。它，它像黄油龙虾味吗？有点黄油味。我要说，更多，更多的是那种螃蟹的方面比较突出。好吧，你想知道为什么吗？这是原料。它是香草豆和黄油基底的龙虾，经过烹饪和切碎。你会拿到围兜吗？我不知道。如果是那样的话，是的。我不知道。不管怎样，我刚才扯远了，因为我觉得这些冰激凌口味太迷人了。好吧，我告诉你这个。
Our ice creams were made up. The names were scripted. Randy Cordray said that Henry Sane built the graphics for the labels. And then, oh no, I'm going to take us down a road. Phil Shea got the ice cream cartons made at a place called Earl Hayes Press. And this is a very famous Hollywood business that mocks up printed items for TV shows and movies. They've been around for a really long time. We used them a lot. Randy sent me their website. Lady, do you remember when I had to go to the old-timey prop house and I just wandered around for like an hour? You called me from there. You were so tickled by it. I think maybe in another life I was meant to be a prop master because I love it. I looked at this website. It's all fakie labels for like made-up food brands. Like,
我们的冰激凌是虚构的。名字是写进剧本里的。兰迪·科德雷说亨利·塞恩为标签制作了图形。然后，哦不，我要带大家走上一条弯路。菲尔·谢伊在一个叫厄尔·海斯压制公司的地方制作了冰激凌盒。这是好莱坞一家非常著名的企业，为电视剧和电影制作印刷品的模型。他们已经存在很长时间了。我们经常使用他们。兰迪把他们的网站发给了我。女士们，你们还记得我不得不去那个老式道具仓库，然后到处闲逛了一个小时左右吗？你从那里给我打了电话。你对此感到非常开心。我想也许在另一辈子里我注定要成为一个道具主管，因为我太喜欢了。我看了这个网站。这全都是虚假标签，针对的是虚构的食品品牌。比如，
they'll make you a fakie cereal, a fakie yogurt, fakie mustard, like anything, you know, so that you, because if you show a real label, you have to get clearance. So you have your graphics design person make you a fakie ketchup label and you then get it made into fakie ketchup at this place. They also do fakie newspaper articles, fakie tabloids, and fakie credit cards. Oh my gosh. Lady, I have a fakie Pam Beasley credit card. Oh, you kept it? Yeah, it was in my prop wallet. I have a library card and a fake credit card. I did not have a fake driver's license, but yeah, that is so cool. I'll take a picture of it and you can put it in stories. But I guess that's where they got it was at this place. I love that companies like that exist. I just think that's so fun.
他们会给你做一个虚构的麦片、虚构的酸奶、虚构的芥末酱，就像任何东西一样，你知道的，为了让你，因为如果你展示真实的标签，你必须获得授权。所以你让你的平面设计人员为你制作一个虚构的番茄酱标签，然后你在那个地方把它做成虚构的番茄酱。他们还制作虚构的报纸文章、虚构的小报和虚构的信用卡。哦天哪。女士，我有一张虚构的潘·比斯利信用卡。哦，你留着它？对，它在我的道具钱包里。我有一张借书证和一张假信用卡。我没有假驾照，但是，是的，太酷了。我会拍一张照片，你可以把它发到快拍里。不过我想他们就是从这个地方得到的。我喜欢这种公司存在。我只是觉得这太有趣了。
That's part of like the movie magic stuff that Randy will share with us that just, I just love the whole process. I know. I find it fascinating. Erin and Pam are going to have a joint talking head and they're going to share their plan for how to handle Michael's broken heart. Yes, we're also going to find out in this talking head that Pam is exhausted because she was up all night with CC. Lady, I had so much fun doing this talking head with Ellie. It's clearly the first time the two of you ever got to do a joint talking head. You were so tickled by it. You guys kept giggling and you were chatty and it's in the bloopers. You have to hear it. You guys are adorable. You're clearly very excited to do this together.
这就像兰迪将与我们分享的电影魔法的一部分，我只是喜欢整个过程。我知道。我觉得很迷人。艾琳和潘妮将有一个联合面对镜头独白，她们将分享她们关于如何处理迈克尔破碎的心脏的计划。是的，我们还将在这个独白中发现潘筋疲力尽，因为她一整晚都陪着西西。女士，我和埃莉一起做这个独白玩得太开心了。这显然是你们两个第一次有机会做一个联合的独白。你们对此感到非常高兴。你们一直咯咯笑，而且很健谈，这都在NG镜头里。你们必须听听。你们太可爱了。你们显然对一起做这件事感到非常兴奋。
Well, this is all for Michael. I'm sorry. Okay. This is our first time to get together. I know. I know. Oh, yeah. Okay. All right. All right. Oh, my God. Are we at work or are we at a sleepover? What's happening? I know. You're like, oh, my God. Oh, my God. Oh, my God. Oh, my God. It's so cute. Like as I watched it and I rewatched the bloopers a few times, I just smiled every time watching the two of you. Well, now Erin and Pam are going to debrief the bullpen about their plan. So here's what they have going on. They are going to play comedy films in the conference room. They've got Mr. Bean playing. They've got Pink Panther ready to go.
好吧，这一切都是为了迈克尔。对不起。好吧。这是我们第一次聚在一起。我知道。我知道。哦，是的。好吧。好吧。好吧。哦，天哪。我们是在工作还是在开睡衣派对？怎么回事？我知道。你就像，哦，天哪。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。太可爱了。就像我看了它，然后我重看了几次NG镜头，每次看你们两个我都禁不住微笑。好吧，现在艾琳和潘妮要在办公区向大家汇报他们的计划。所以这就是他们的安排。他们要在会议室播放喜剧电影。他们在放《憨豆先生》。他们准备好了《粉红豹》。
They have a signup list so that people can watch movies with Michael. Pam also tells everyone they need to keep their conversations light. Do not empathize with Michael because it just encourages him. And if you can't think of something to do, just make a random sound effect. And also they should laugh at anything he says that might possibly be funny. The random sound effect was my favorite thing. My favorite thing is that Toby walks through the door and everybody is like, no, please get out. I have a catch from this scene at three minutes and 49 seconds. It is a proof of cold. You can see the heater under my desk. The light is on. Yeah, I saw it. Well, Michael's going to
他们有一个报名表，这样人们就可以和迈克尔一起看电影了。潘妮还告诉大家，他们需要保持谈话轻松。不要对迈克尔产生共情，因为这只会助长他的气焰。如果你想不出要做什么，就随机做一个音效。还有，对于他说的任何可能很有趣的话，他们都应该笑。随机音效是我最喜欢的部分。我最喜欢的部分是托比走进门，每个人都说，不，请出去。我在三分钟四十九秒时捕捉到了这个场景的一个细节。这是一个供暖的证据。你可以看到我办公桌下的取暖器。灯亮着。是的，我看到了。好吧，迈克尔要
come in and he gets the warmest welcome. Erin hugs him, Dwight compliments his tie. Everyone is laughing at his jokes. Pam offers him ice cream. Yeah, he's loving it, but he just kind of walks into his office. He doesn't seem upset. And everyone's like, huh, maybe he's going to take this one better than the others. But maybe there's another reason why he's not upset, which we will find out soon. Well, lady, now Angela and Dwight are in the conference room and they are reviewing their contract with their mediator. So like I said earlier in the fast fact, the mediator was played by Bruno Oliver. And Aaron sure told us that he named him Mr. Barr after a friend of his, whose last name was also Barr, who was also a mediator. And Aaron consulted
进来了，他受到了最热烈的欢迎。艾琳拥抱了他，德怀特夸奖了他的领带。每个人都在笑他的笑话。潘妮给他冰激凌。是的，他很喜欢，但他只是径直走回了自己的办公室。他看起来并不沮丧。每个人都在想，哈，也许他会比其他人更能接受这个打击。但也许他没有沮丧还有另一个原因，我们很快就会知道。好吧，女士们，现在安吉拉和德怀特在会议室里，他们正在与调解员审查他们的协议。所以就像我在快讯里早些时候说的，调解员由布鲁诺·奥利弗扮演。艾琳确实告诉我们，他把他命名为巴尔先生，是为了纪念他的一个朋友，那个朋友的姓也是巴尔，也是个调解员。艾琳咨询了
her for advice on what a mediator might realistically do in this insane situation. And Aaron also sent in an audio clip and he shared a little memory about this runner, this storyline, which he really loved. Hi office ladies, it's Aaron. Sure. What I remember about shooting the chump is that I decided to bring my son to work. And it's a little risky, bring a 10 year old onto a set, even a friendly set like ours. But my son was having a blast. He didn't realize what a cool job his dad had at the time. I mean, now I'm sure his bumble profile says my dad wrote for the office, but then he was just meeting really charismatic, funny people and eating a lot of fun food. And rain came up and was charming my son. But at one point,
她关于调解员在这个疯狂的情况下可能会现实地做些什么的建议。艾琳还发来了一个音频剪辑，他分享了关于这个次要情节、这个他真的很喜欢的故事情节的一点回忆。嗨，办公室女士们，我是艾琳·希尔。我关于拍摄《笨蛋》一集的记忆是，我决定带我儿子去上班。带一个十岁的孩子去片场有点冒险，即使是对我们这样友好的片场也是如此。但我儿子玩得很开心。他当时并没有意识到他爸爸有一份多酷的工作。我的意思是，现在我敢肯定他的大黄蜂约会软件个人资料上写着我爸爸为《办公室》编剧，但当时他只是在遇到非常有魅力、有趣的人，并且吃了很多好玩的食物。雷恩走过来，吸引了我儿子。但有一刻，
rain leans over to him and says, Hey, listen, buddy, I need to talk to your dad for a minute, because this negotiation scene is not hitting on all cylinders. And I'm like, Oh, okay, son, have a cookie. I mean, in fact, have all the cookies you want. I'm going to go talk to Mr. Wilson, because if he thinks the scene is not working, the scene is not working. And rain's like, I'm not saying it's not working. I'm just saying some of the bits feel a little forced. So basically, rain and I negotiated the negotiation scene with my son as the mediator, chomping on a cookie. And I did do a hectic rewrite over lunch, none of which got in. That was any better. That's the beauty of the documentary style. Pro tip. If you're going to
雷恩倾身对他说，嘿，听着，伙计，我需要和你爸爸谈一会儿，因为这个谈判场景没有发挥到极致。我说，哦，好吧，儿子，吃个饼干。我的意思是，事实上，吃所有你想吃的饼干。我要去和威尔逊先生谈谈，因为如果他认为这个场景行不通，这个场景就是行不通。雷恩说，我不是说它行不通。我只是说有些桥段感觉有点勉强。所以基本上，雷恩和我以我儿子作为调解员、嚼着饼干谈判了谈判场景。我在午餐时确实疯狂地重写了剧本，但没有一个被采用。没有哪个更好。这就是纪录片风格的魅力。专业提示。如果你打算
make a hit show, make it documentary style, because then you just keep the parts that work like Angela with red teeth because of her beat fast. Oh my gosh, Aaron, I cannot believe you did that rewrite. I do remember rain pulling him aside. I remember we were going through stuff. And there were so many more scenes between Dwight and Angela. If you have the DVD box set, they're in deleted scenes. And there's also a bunch in the bloopers because we couldn't keep it together. In fact, the very first time we meet the mediator, the very first few sentences, we just started laughing. Here it is. It's in the bloopers. And then we have a joint talking head where Dwight and Angela share that rather than spend
拍一部热门剧，用纪录片风格拍，因为那样你就可以保留那些起作用的部分，比如安吉拉因为喝甜菜汁而满嘴红牙。哦天哪，艾琳，我简直不敢相信你做了那个重写。我确实记得雷恩把他拉到一边。我记得我们正在过剧本。德怀特和安吉拉之间还有更多的场景。如果你有 DVD 套装，它们就在被删减场景里。而且在NG镜头里也有一堆，因为我们实在憋不住笑。事实上，我们第一次见到调解员的时候，头几句台词，我们就开始笑了。就是这个。它在NG镜头里。然后我们有一个联合采访，德怀特和安吉拉在其中分享说，与其花
all day in court, they've decided to mediate this childbearing contract dispute. And they go back and forth. Dwight's like alleged contract. Angela's like alleged, I could own your farm by the time we're done with this. We couldn't get through this talking head either. Rather than spend the whole day in court, we decided to settle our dispute using a mediator. It was one of the options spelled out in our childbearing contract alleged contract. What are you talking about? The contract is alleged. You wrote the contract, Dwight. You're notary was out of date. Sorry. We had so much fun. Just the idea that Dwight and Angela would have this contract in the first place and then be disputing it and involve a mediator. Rain and I could not stop doing bits.
一整天的时间在法庭上，他们决定通过调解来解决这个生育合同纠纷。他们争执不休。德怀特说所谓的合同。安吉拉说所谓的，等我们谈完，我都可以买下你的农场了。这个采访我们也拍不下去。与其花一整天在法庭上，我们决定用调解员来解决我们的纠纷。这是我们生育合同中列出的选项之一。所谓的合同。你在说什么？合同是所谓的。合同是你写的，德怀特。你的公证员过期了。抱歉。我们玩得太开心了。光是德怀特和安吉拉首先会有这份合同，然后对此产生争议并让调解员介入这个想法。雷恩和我根本停不下来。我们演了那些写在剧本里的东西。我们稍微玩了一下。简直是太棒了。
We got to do stuff that was scripted. We got to play around a little bit. It was just the best. That must have been so much fun to shoot. I mean, I loved every second and there are so many in deleted scenes. Well, Dwight is really trying to pick apart this contract. He's trying to find some way that maybe Angela is in breach of contract to make it null and void. And the first thing he brings up is whether or not Angela has been following the beet juice cleanse. Apparently, I guess to prepare your body for baby, you're supposed to do a beet juice cleanse. But Angela is like, oh, no, no, I'm doing it. Look at my teeth. And your teeth are red, Ang. They're really red. If you go to five minutes,
拍摄那场戏一定超级好玩。我的意思是，我喜欢每一秒钟，被删减场景里有那么多东西。好吧，德怀特真的在试图挑剔这份合同。他试图找到某种方法，也许安吉拉违约了，从而使合同无效。他提出的第一件事是安吉拉是否一直在遵循甜菜汁排毒法。显然，我想为了让你的身体为生孩子做好准备，你应该做一个甜菜汁排毒。但安吉拉却说，哦，不，不，我在做。看我的牙齿。安吉拉，你的牙齿是红色的。真的红了。如果你看五分钟，
seven seconds, you'll see also a fun little game. If you want to rewatch this episode is you can see when my teeth are stained and when they aren't. We go back and forth within the same scene. I noticed that. Well, we had a fan question from Cameron D and Richmond, Virginia, who said, what did you use for the beet stained teeth? Angela, was it gross? Were your teeth really stained? And Leanne H from Lake Stevens, Washington said, as a dental hygienist, I was wondering how Angela's beet stained teeth were achieved because the color looks similar to a dental disclosing solution used to show patients where they are missing plaque with their brushing. I'm wondering, did you get your teeth really dirty and then use the solution?
七秒，你还会看到一个有趣的小游戏。如果你想重温这一集，你可以看到我的牙齿什么时候是染过色的，什么时候没有。我们在同一场戏里来回切换。我注意到了。好吧，我们有一个来自弗吉尼亚州里士满的卡梅伦·D的粉丝提问，他说，你用什么来染红牙齿的？安吉拉，恶心吗？你的牙齿真的被染色了吗？华盛顿州莱克史蒂文斯的莉安·H说，作为一名牙科保健师，我想知道安吉拉被甜菜染红的牙齿是如何实现的，因为颜色看起来类似于牙科显色液，用来向患者展示他们在刷牙时哪里漏掉了牙菌斑。我想知道，你的牙齿是不是真的很脏，然后用了那个溶液？
No, Leanne, I didn't do that. But I will tell you, Kenneth Paul, who did my makeup, we did a few tests on my teeth. He had like a cotton swab. He also used like a little brush and he had, it looked like a red food dye. It had no taste. So it didn't taste gross, but it really made my teeth red. And I thought we knocked this out of the park. I thought the teeth looked really red. Kenneth Paul was happy with it. Even when I walked to set, I would forget that my teeth were stained and I would start talking to people and people would wince. They'd go, ah, and I actually became self conscious while I had my teeth stained because everyone had such a reaction to it. But I remember they wanted my teeth even redder, Jenna.
不，莉安，我没有那样做。但我会告诉你，负责我妆容的肯尼斯·保尔，对我的牙齿做了一些测试。他拿了一个棉签。他还用了一个小刷子，他有，看起来像红色的食用色素。它没有任何味道。所以吃起来并不恶心，但它真的把我的牙齿染红了。我以为我们大获成功。我认为牙齿看起来真的很红。肯尼斯·保尔对此很满意。甚至当我走到片场时，我会忘记我的牙齿被染色了，然后我开始和人们说话，人们会畏缩。他们会说，啊，当我的牙齿被染红时，我实际上变得很不自在，因为每个人对此的反应都太强烈了。但我记得他们想让我的牙齿更红，珍娜。
Yeah, I guess this was a rather involved gag. Randy Cordray said that, yes, in person. It was reading if we were speaking to you. But I guess like when they were looking at it and editing, it just didn't look red enough. So they actually sent the shot of you showing your teeth to a visual effects company called Encore Video. And they added red to your teeth in post. Well, it really made me laugh. I had forgotten just how much of a visual gag it was until I rewatched it. And I was like, oh my gosh. Well, lady, I got curious about the beet juice cleanse because I assumed this was just like a joke because of Dwight having a beet farm. But I guess it's it's actually a thing. What kind of cleanse is it? Well, according to justbeatit.com,
是的，我想这是一个相当复杂的恶作剧。兰迪·科德雷说，是的，在现场。如果我们跟你说话，它看起来是红的。但我想当他们在观看和剪辑时，它看起来不够红。所以他们实际上把那个展示牙齿的镜头发送给了一家名为安可视频（Encore Video）的视觉特效公司。他们在后期制作中把你的牙齿加红了。嗯，这真的把我逗笑了。我忘了它是一个多么具有视觉效果的恶作剧，直到我重看了一遍，然后我想，哦天哪。好吧，女士，我对甜菜汁排毒法产生了好奇，因为我以为这只是一个笑话，因为德怀特有一个甜菜农场。但我想这实际上是一回事。这到底是什么样的排毒法？好吧，根据 justbeatit.com 网站
the EET, I love it, quote, an epic detoxifier that eliminates toxins from the liver beats promote healthy liver function. And according to tastylicious.com beats have several essential health benefits that can help detoxify your body and give your organs and immune system a much needed boost. Aside from being healthy and packed full of vitamins, a beet juice cleanse has been known to help a range of conditions and ailments. And it is the perfect food to prevent aging and to battle inflammation. Well, now I'm thinking we need to do a beet cleanse. I mean, after drinking your beet juice vodka, lady, I mean, I don't know. You really were not a fan. It's just that it was so dry. It's very earthy. Well, what I want to know is, is there a beet
juice ice cream? Has anyone done that? I'm sure flavor. I'm positive there is one out there somewhere. I would try that. You would try beet ice cream, probably not the same health benefits as a beet juice cleanse. Incidentally, I could not really find any instructions for a beet juice cleanse. I could just find that beet juice is good for you. Well, now in the kitchen, Andy, Jim, Pam and Phyllis are discussing how Michael just seems okay. You know, has he evolved? Has he matured? He's not crying. He's really handling this breakup well. I know. And Jim's like, so what? He just matured overnight. And Andy's like, that's what happened in big. Yeah. Well, Pam and Jim are going to make an announcement.
This was so well done. I thought you and John crushed this moment because you look so weary and inviting Michael to come to your house and play with your baby and you order food to go from Hooters. You look so pained as you're saying all of it, Jenna. It just cracked me up. It reminded me of the scene where Pam is trying to get Michael to talk to her, so she tells him that she needs to discuss her sex life with him. Yeah. They really know Michael well. They do. Even after all of these promises, Michael is going to take a rain check. And that is when Pam says, are you still seeing Donna? She yells it across the bullpen. I wrote down the time code five minutes and 56 seconds into the episode. I couldn't believe it. Like I was like,
wow, Pam, I have something to say about this scene. One of the things that Pam offers to do with Michael is play rock band. She says they'll play Billy Joel songs on rock band. Now, first of all, Billy Joel songs were never on rock band. He hadn't given permission to use his songs. So this is something that we made up. And the reason that I would know this is because I got really, really into rock band for a while. And I don't know if you remember, but I used to come to set and I used to talk about it. And I even had some folks over to my house for a barbecue to play rock band. And I kind of like to imagine that maybe that's how rock band made it into this episode. I do remember you having a thing for rock band. I was not part of it. No, lady, I know that you
couldn't because it was a late night thing and you had a child and I was still a baby. You were my friend who was still playing video games late at night. Exactly. I'm sure this was me at my most annoying for you as a new mother. But you did love it. It had to have made its way in because of you. I'm going to co-sign on that. Okay, thank you. Well, now Michael is going to have his orange lips talking head. Yeah. What? Right? I noticed it too. Yeah. He has this talking head where he says he likes Donna. And if it's wrong to keep seeing her, he doesn't care. And he has orange lips. And the message boards after this episode had all these comments. Why did Michael have orange lips? Were there any fan theories? Because I have one. There was a fan theory. First of all, there was no
mention of it in the script. But the one fan theory is that his lips are stained from kissing Donna who wears red lipstick. Okay. Here was my theory. Okay. So later in the episode, he comes in with all of these oranges. And I wondered if maybe we shot out of order and see a bunch of oranges. Oh my gosh, lady. I'm going to go with you. I mean, I don't know. Well, how many oranges do you have to eat for your lips to take on some color? But that's all I could think of was, well, we really did eat a bunch of oranges. We did. You might be right. Well, the bullpen is really going to confront Michael on having this affair. Even Meredith is like, Hey, I've never cheated, been cheated on, or used to cheat with. She has a whole talking head where she says she asks everyone in
the room if they are in a relationship. Yeah. She has standards. But out in the bullpen, Michael is going to defend himself. He says we are the Paris of Northeastern Pennsylvania. And in Paris, it is rude for a woman to have any less than four lovers. He's just one of Donna's four Parisian lovers. Yeah. And he also says her husband is like a scummy sports guy. And Andy's like, Wait a second, Michael, are you making assumptions here? And Michael just doesn't want to hear it. Mm hmm. I want to point out at seven minutes, three seconds, there is a great shot of the whole entire bullpen. And if you notice, Dwight and Angela are not in this scene. Well, are you in the conference room? Yes, we're in the conference room. But it meant that Rain and I had part of
the day off. Oh, because we don't even see you in the background of the conference room. That's right. Lady, whenever I would get a script where I clearly had a storyline that was like segmented off from the other storylines, and I knew that I would have days off, I would get so excited, and I would go to Randy or to Jenny O'Keeffe, who planned our schedule. And I would say, What day are you going to shoot the stuff I'm not in? Because that was the day that I could like go to the doctor, you know, you could make your doctor's appointment, or whatever you needed to do that were like things that have to happen during daytime working hours that we could never do. Yeah. Andy is going to share that he is a cuckold, which is a Shakespearean term for a man
whose woman is cheating on him. And you know what, he lived it, and he doesn't ever want to do it again. Yeah, Andy has a very personal attachment to this issue with Michael. He is going to kind of take it on. Yes, he's going to confront Michael about it in Michael's office. Andy says in any cheating movie, the person getting cheated on is the hero. You're Ali Larder, I'm Beyonce. To which Michael says, I am Beyonce always. Yeah. Yeah. We had a fan question from Cassie M in Brisbane, Australia. When Andy goes to try and talk Michael into understanding that what he is doing is wrong, he references the Ali Larder and Beyonce movie obsessed. Well, that movie has Idris Elba, aka Charles Miner in it. And I just thought it was funny that the office was in a world where
Idris Elba exists and Michael knows him from the movie, but also Charles Miner exists as a completely different person. Oh my gosh, we're in the matrix. We are. Well, somehow Andy is going to convince Michael that they should go meet Donna's husband, that they should scope him out. And Michael thinks that's great because then Andy will see what a bad person he is. Yeah. Michael says he can't wait to see this jerk who's making him cheat on his wife and that he should punch him in the face for what he's making Michael do to her. Yeah. Well, listen, should we take a break before we go to this baseball game lady? Yes, because at the baseball game, we're going to meet Andy's alternate persona, Trevor. And I can't wait to share with you about Trevor. We are at a baseball game. Andy is really into
it. He's singing. He's making up sort of like baseball commentary. Michael's like, can you just act normal? Just, you know, blend in. Andy's like, I am the one blending in. Yeah, it's kind of true. I mean, you want to show support of your team. At nine minutes and 21 seconds, I have a couple of cool background catches. There are two background actors sitting next to Andy and Michael wearing custom Scranton Wolverine t-shirts. And behind Michael and Andy, I spotted a background person who is having their best day ever. As someone who was a background performer, I saw this person and I thought, that's a great gig. I would have been so happy to have that gig. Lady, they have their earphones in. They only have one in, you know, so they've got one ear free to listen to the action.
And then they are probably just listening to whatever, a podcast, their favorite music. Their job that day was to sit on a bench behind Ed Helms and Steve Carell and just listen to whatever they wanted to all day in the fresh air and sunshine. Yeah, when I was on 90210 as a background performer, I would get very excited when we would have sorority meetings because we were just indoors in the air conditioning and I just got to sit there. Yeah. Well, lady, you know what I'm just remembering now, and I can't believe I didn't bring this up earlier. My best day as a background performer was the day that I played a field hockey player in a phone commercial and it was shot outside of the city. And so I actually got to ride on a bus with all the other background
performers. We stayed overnight in a hotel. They just gave me like a random roommate. Yeah, but it was like a little vacation. And then the next day, I pretended to be a field hockey player because I because I was able to put that down on my background casting list because of my high school field hockey experience. But I don't think I would have qualified for smitties. I was gonna say I was not professional level field. Barbara would have hung up on you. She did hang up on me earlier today. Back of the office, Jim and Pam are completely asleep at their deaths. Yeah. And they get busted. Well, Jim was supposed to be the lookout. Gabe says, come to my office, which cracks me up because he doesn't have an office. He just has a desk outside of the break room. Yeah. But he's like,
please come to my office. And they're like, oh, crap. Yeah, he forgives them pretty quickly because they take responsibility. But then he starts droning on and on. And Pam and Jim start dozing off while he's talking. This is such a relatable moment. We have all been in some meeting and just fighting to stay awake, fighting to keep your eyes open. Well, sleep deprivation is a real thing. I have suffered from it. Lady, I'm sure you've suffered from it, right? Yeah. Well, according to the sleep foundation, a third of adults suffer from sleep deprivation, like at any given time. So let me ask you, how much sleep do you get per night on average, would you say? Oh, gosh, it just depends. I mean, you know, we still are at that age where if you have a kid
that can't sleep, they come in your room, you know, anywhere from five hours to eight hours, if I'm lucky. They recommend that adults get seven to nine hours of sleep per night. Here are the primary signs of sleep deprivation. Slowed thinking, reduced attention span, worsened memory, poor or risky decision making, lack of energy and feelings of stress, anxiety or irritability. Yeah. You are also more likely to crave junk food and gain weight if you aren't getting enough sleep because you start eating to kind of like compensate for the energy that you didn't get at night. I mean, yeah. Well, I can definitely relate to the irritability because I feel like, you know, I definitely get grumpy when I don't get sleep. Yeah. I get grouchy if I haven't had
enough sleep. And I also get grouchy if I haven't had enough to eat. So you do not want to catch me on a sleep deprived day while I'm also hungry. That would be bad news. I feel like I've been with you on one of those days. Oh, lady, I'm sure you have. It's a travel day sometimes. We don't get food when we need it and we're tired. Yes, exactly. I love that they're meeting with Gabe and with Gabe being like, okay, so great. And they're like, what? What was he even talking about? They have no idea. They've just agreed to help him do something and they have no idea what he said. Well, over in the conference room, the mediator says, I have to tell you, this is a solid contract and Dwight is shocked that he could not find any holes in this contract. Not only that, the mediator
says, listen, I can't force someone to have a child with another person. So Dwight, you have to pay Angela $30,000 in damages. Yeah. Dwight refuses to pay Angela. He doesn't have that kind of money, he says. I mean, he has it, but it's buried very deep and he would have to dig past a certain person to get it. So Angela presents him with an alternative idea. How about they have intercourse to completion, five individual times rendered at her discretion. And Dwight agrees. The mediator's like, this is getting dangerously close to prostitution. So I might have to step back here. I want you guys to know, Phil Shea made us prop procreation punch cards that you have and put in our book. That's right, that I still have. It's in our book, The Office BFFs. Four weeks on
the New York Times bestseller list. Yeah. Yeah. It tickles me. I open my desk drawer. I keep it right in my top desk drawer. I see it almost every day. My procreation punch card. NBC.com at this time also shared Dwight and Angela's procreation contract. What? Yeah. It's in web archives. You can still see it. There is a lot is pages long. Oh my God. I'm going to read you just a few things that were on this very long and detailed contract. Number one, if the child is breached, he must be turned around in the womb via mind power. I'm guessing Dwight wrote that one. Number two, should the child have mutant powers, parties agree to send the child to a school that aids the child in harnessing his talents for good. Okay. I think Dwight also wrote that one.
Number three, see if you can guess who wrote this one. Child shall not have a puppy, dog, nor any toys shaped like puppies or dogs. Cats should be treated with high regard and all other animals regarded only for their usefulness and meat. Yeah. I think that's a combo, Angela and Dwight, contribution. It is so funny to me how detailed this contract is. You know our writers had a lot of fun with it and it's still archived on the internet. I could not love that more. I would buy that as a little mini booklet, pamphlet thing if someone would print it. Well, speaking of cats, Dwight is going to have a stipulation that their intercourse cannot take place in Angela's lumpy bed. This is one of my
favorite Angela speeches. Fans quoted to me, I thought we should hear it. But not in your bed, it's lumpy. Those lumps are cats and those cats have names and those names are Ember, Milky Way, Diane, and Lumpy. We had a fan question lady from Abby S in Atlanta, Georgia. What does Abby want to know? Abby would like to know why Angela does not mention Bandit, Princess Lady, Mr. Ash, or Petals. She only mentions Ember, Milky Way, Diane, and Lumpy. Is this because the other cats are not allowed to sleep in the bed? Oh, I think Princess Lady has her own bed. That's right next to Angela's bed. I mean, there might be some senior cats that have special needs. There is a system. Don't doubt it. All cats are sleeping perfectly where
they're supposed to, and they are treated very well. Okay, good. Thank you for clearing that up. Back in the baseball field, Andy says it seems like Donna's husband, Coach Shane, is really well liked. And Michael's like, oh, look how he high fives people. He probably does that to Donna. Donna, you did the dishes. High five. Michael is really trying here to find fault in Coach Shane. The next scene at the baseball field is super cringy because they are going to speak to Coach Shane. It's awkward. It's so awkward. Andy can't stop talking. He's what you're later going to find out. He's playing his character, Trevor. He's also going to introduce Coach Shane to his friend Sheldon. Yes. And then Michael and Shane are going to have a very awkward
handshake through the fence. At 13 minutes and six seconds, we had a fan catch from Joshua P and Cincinnati who said, what is the story with the bleachers at this baseball game? Earlier at the game, there are several rows of bleachers behind Michael and Andy, but in this scene, they suddenly disappear and you can see just background behind Michael, were these scenes shot on different days or in different locations? Well, this is a really good catch, Joshua. I thought the same thing. I was like, oh my gosh, they are on different bleachers. That is because in the script, it was scripted as such, quote, Michael and Andy now take seats closer to the foul. And this is so they can talk to Shane. But we cut out the part where you see
them move. So it looks like they sort of instantaneously are sitting somewhere else. Well, Michael is going to have a talking head and his back is going to be to the field. He's going to say his heart is racing because he just shook the hand of this man who he's having an affair with his wife. And you know, who else does that? James Frickin Bond. During this talking head, Jenna, there was a pop fly that was hurtling toward Steve, but his back was towards the field and he didn't see it coming. It's in the bloopers, Randall Einhorn quickly steps forward and grabs Steve. Oh my gosh. Yeah. And then, of course, they're all like, everyone okay, everyone okay? And Steve does a funny bit because
the way he ducked, it looks like an awkward dance move. He's like, oh, that's crazy. Oh my gosh. I thought you were going to say that Randall Einhorn reached out and caught the ball. Oh, that would have been amazing just with like one bare hand. Yeah, that's very Randall. So Andy's plan of trying to shame Michael does not work. Michael is emboldened. He returns to the office. He's throwing out orange slices. He hits Oscar with an orange slice. Oscar says, why would you throw something wet at me? Remind me of Pam's line, please don't throw garbage at me. Me too. We find out he stole the orange slices from the team. Well, it's not the first thing he took from Coach Shane. Oh, you know, by the way, at 14 minutes and 52 seconds, we're going to see
that orange slice hit Oscar's shirt and it leaves a wet spot. Yeah. But at 15 minutes 30 seconds, Oscar has another line. And I noticed it as well as Christian B from Chattanooga, Tennessee, that Oscar no longer has a stain from orange hitting him in the shoulder. I caught that too. It has magically disappeared. Well, this is when Andy tells the group, you know what, he doesn't condone this affair. He even tried to get Michael to meet Coach Shane. Here is the deleted storyline that I loved so much. Andy actually had more to say to the bullpen that got cut. Here's what was in the shooting draft. Andy, I just want to say that I do not condone this. And I tried everything to stop it, including adopting a persona of Trevor, a nosy but affable
stranger who asks super leading guilt tripping questions. And then it would have gone to a talking head where Andy explains who Trevor is. You have to hear it. Exactly. Who is Trevor? Well, he's a regular guy with a passing interest in high school sports. It's a bit of a foodie, loves documentaries. If you were to ask Trevor who he is, he'd probably just say, I'm a dad. But with layers, you know, he's actually inquisitive, which gets underneath those layers. I don't know, he's just a delight. I agree. I love Trevor. I mean, I love Trevor. I think Andy wants to be Trevor. Now Kelly and Ryan are having just one of their silly arguments in the kitchen. Michael's going to enter and just take Meredith's birthday cake and just start eating it.
Jenna, this is in the bloopers. I think there's like five takes of Steve eating that cake. And they kept laughing because he had to talk with such a big mouthful. But it cracked me up because you really see how many takes that we do sometimes. And Steve had to do take after take, taking this huge bite of cake. Steve is very, very funny when he talks with food in his mouth. He really is. He's a very funny comedic eat talker. I don't know what that talent is, but he should put it on his resume. I noticed in this scene that the cake box says that it's from Fresh from Mom's Bakery. But I could not find a local Scranton Bakery with this name. It made me wonder if it was a fakie box that we had made from the fakie food making people. I bet it's fakie box. It was a
real cake. And I did notice it was not an ice cream cake. So we didn't make that mistake again as the party planning committee. That's right. Ryan is so enamored by this version of Michael. He's like, wow, Michael takes what he wants. And this inspires him to march up to Aaron's desk at front reception and tell her he finds her attractive. He wants to sleep with her. She's like, what about Kelly? And he's like, yeah. And she's like, is this a joke? And immediately he backpedals and he's like, yup. This would have rounded out the Ryan threesome storyline that started in Secretary's Day. It was in the deleted scenes that I shared about. He just was determined to have a little tryst with Kelly and Aaron. Our next montage is explained in a Dwight talking
head where we learn that Dwight is going to try to sabotage his sperm count by doing a number of things to his testicles. Yeah, he's going to hold a microwave that's microwaving something to his crotch. He's going to bang on his balls with drumsticks, throw yellow pages at his crotch, and also bounce harshly on a bicycle and then crash into a door. I was curious if any of these things would reduce his sperm count. Oh gosh. I'll tell you Dwight is doing all the wrong things. What should he be doing? Well, first of all, I believe he's microwaving a cup of coffee. If he wants to reduce his sperm count, he should drink lots and lots and lots of coffee because too much coffee can reduce your sperm count. Also, he should try to make
his crotch very, very warm by sitting in a sauna. These are according to U Chicago Medicine. Warm crotch. Warm crotch. Also, if he ate too much of certain foods like foods high in soy products or high fat dairy products, that could reduce his sperm count. Yeah. So, well Dwight, you didn't have to bang on your balls so much. You didn't. Your sperm is going to be hardy. Incidentally, another thing that I read is that you know that myth where if you ejaculate less, you'll have more sperm. Maybe the sperm will be more potent when you do want to conceive. Have you heard that myth? You know, like you're trying to conceive a child and so don't masturbate. Right. Okay. Because you want to save it for the baby making. Save it up. Yeah, no. You should ejaculate more. Oh,
no. It doesn't work that way. It doesn't like save up the sperm. It's not like a little bank. You don't have a bank in your testes. That's right. So actually, you should ejaculate daily and that will increase your sperm count, folks. So really what we needed was a scene of Dwight drinking coffee with soy milk in a sauna. Yeah. That would have worked. Well, the printer is out of paper. Michael isn't even going to add more. Creed, like Ryan, is like, wow, he don't give an F about nothing. Yeah, exactly. Michael's going to say he's got big balls. But Phyllis is going to be the one who I think finally gets to Michael. The scene is so funny. Phyllis not making eye contact with Michael cracked me up. Mm hmm. Michael's going to pretend like it didn't get to him and he's going
to leave the office and he's going to start driving to a motel where he's going to meet up with Donna. I have a little background catch while he's driving and thinking, you know, he's really contemplating what's happening. Yes. His seatbelt is still frayed. Remember in Secretary's day? I love it. Yeah. We talked about a deleted scene where Michael tells Aaron when he's stressed out, sometimes he chews on his seatbelt. Well, I thought that this driving location looked new. This did not look like our usual driving street without the palm trees. They're rolling hills. I asked Randy about it and he actually said, good eye, Jenna, which made me feel proud. And he confirmed that it was a stretch of road in Santa Clarita that was
next to the baseball field on Rockwell Canyon Road. Well, that explains it. Guys, Michael does not make it to the motel. He leaves Donna high and dry. We see her sitting in her car waiting for him. Do you know what that hotel was, Ange? No, but it had a bright orange door. Yeah. Do you know the Tangerine Hotel in Burbank? Oh, is it now? You would know it if you drove by it. Yes, I do. That was the hotel we used. And it has the bright orange door. Yeah. I couldn't believe it. Randy told me that. I was like, yes. Oh, my gosh. I knew, I knew it, but I didn't know how I knew it. It's still there, famous hotel. Michael's going to have a
talking head where he tells us that he feels good. He broke up with Donna and he knows he made the right decision. But then, of course, he broke my heart a little bit. He had to choose between happiness or living with himself. And he chose living with himself, which means he had to give up his happiness. Yeah. And now he's going to be, you know, lonely again. Yeah. But he does the right thing. He does the right thing. And he's going to go back to the office and grab his ice cream. Mm-hmm. Pam and Jim don't know if they can make it through the rest of the day. They're really struggling. And Daryl tells them where they can go to sleep in the warehouse. There's this little secret spot. Daryl loves it so much, sometimes he thinks about it when he's at home
trying to go to sleep. I don't know if this was on the bloopers, Angela, but we could not get through this scene with Craig when Craig was like wistfully talking about the sleeping spot, like his voice. He's like, sometimes I think about it so warm, like we would laugh. It was so funny. It's not in the bloopers, but there is a really funny Daryl talking head in the bloopers from this episode. It was deleted, so it's not in the episode. But Daryl shares that he used to cheat, but then he watched the movie Love Actually and that really set him straight and really got to him. And he kept laughing through it, and it's really funny. Well, I guess Angela has picked one of her moments, one of her five moments with Dwight, and they are going to rendezvous back in their
meeting place in the warehouse. Dwight says, Angela, are you warmed up? She says, no. And he goes, why is that always my responsibility? And then they go in and they shut the door and she goes, what have you done to yourself? You start hearing some noises. He's like, no kissing. This is a really awkward thing to overhear. And guess who's overhearing it? Yeah, Jim and Pam. Poor Jim and Pam. All they wanted to do was go to this special little sleeping nook that Daryl told them about in the warehouse. And now they're overhearing Dwight and Angela. So I have to tell you, getting to our sleeping spot was actually very complicated. Yeah, you guys are up really high. Yes, we are actually up on a shelf in the warehouse. It's a special thing that they built. Randy reminded me
that we actually had to practice getting up there using a scissor lift. Wow. And it involved a whole rehearsal the week prior with a Universal Studios safety officer named Ian Bass Gillespie. This person was in attendance to sign off on our use of the scissor lift. And it was a big deal. But we made it up there. And we're laying truly up on this high shelf in this little nook. And I will tell you right now, it was so comfy, cozy. It was everything that Daryl advertised it to be. And it was a dream to just sort of get to kind of nap for part of my workday. All I could think about when I saw you guys up there was, what if you have to pee? That's what I always think. Like, could you imagine? That is why I never want to sleep on the top bunk of a bunk bed. I know.
Well, we had a fan question from Michelle S. in Melbourne, Australia that I thought was very wise. Michelle said, the spot where the warehouse guys take their naps is right above Dwight and Angela's sex spot. Does this mean that the warehouse guys know about Dwight and Angela's affair? I mean, they've been there the whole time. I think the warehouse guys do know about your affair. Oh, for sure. I don't think you guys are hiding it from them at all. Clearly, we haven't been hiding it very well from anyone. Exactly. Well, the episode is going to end with Michael exiting the building and he's approached by a news team. The reporter says, Michael Scott, do you want to make a comment on the rumors?
Michael sighs. He's like, ah, I have done some very bad things, things of which I am not proud. I would like to publicly apologize to the coach and the players and I vow to never listen to my bodily instincts ever again. The reporter is confused. She says, I'm talking about the saber printers that catch on fire. And Michael's like, oh, okay, I was talking about what, wait, what? Yeah. So Randy told me that this was like a standards and practices issue. This scene. This scene. Why? That's what I asked. He said that they wanted us to create a fictitious news channel. They didn't want us to use the real NBC affiliate, which is WBRE. But we had established WBRE in the show before. So they had to get a signed clearance agreement from the real WBRE
迈克尔叹了口气。他好像在说，啊，我做了一些非常糟糕的事，一些让我感到羞耻的事。我想向教练和球员们公开道歉，我发誓再也不听从我身体的本能了。记者很困惑。她说，我说的是那些会着火的赛博打印机。迈克尔的反应是，哦，好吧，我说的是什么，等等，什么？是的。所以兰迪告诉我这就像是一个标准和实践的问题。这个场景。这个场景。为什么？这就是我问的。他说他们希望我们创建一个虚构的新闻频道。他们不想让我们使用真正的NBC分支机构，也就是WBRE。但我们之前已经在节目中建立过WBRE。所以他们不得不从真正的WBRE获得一份签署的许可协议
in Scranton. And eventually we were given a pass so that we could use the actual call letters in the show. Oh, yeah. And you can see it very clearly on the microphone. Mm-hmm. Yeah. Well, this is going to set up a huge story arc now for Michael. He's going to end up being the spokesperson for Sabre. Joe is going to come back. It's all going to go down next week in the whistleblower. Yes. The season finale whistleblower. Well, that was the chump. Thank you for rewatching with us. Thank you so much, Aaron Scherr, for sending in those audio clips and sharing with us about writing this episode. Thank you to Randy Cordray for always giving us awesome behind-the-scenes details. And I would like to thank whoever put together that blooper reel on the season six
在斯克兰顿。最终我们获准在节目中使用实际的呼号。哦，是的。你可以在麦克风上非常清楚地看到它。嗯哼。是的。好吧，这将为迈克尔铺垫一个巨大的故事主线。他最终将成为赛博的代言人。乔将会回来。这一切都将在下周的《吹哨人》中上演。是的。季终集《吹哨人》。好了，这就是全部。谢谢你和我们一起重温。非常感谢亚伦·舍尔发来这些音频剪辑，并与我们分享撰写这一集的经历。感谢兰迪·科德雷总是提供精彩的幕后细节。我要感谢所有在第六季中制作了那个NG花絮集锦的人
DVD because much like Trevor, I am finding it delightful. I would like to thank my engineer Casey here in New York. We did this podcast with me in New York and Angela in Los Angeles. Casey and I might take off right now and get some of that lobster ice cream. Okay. Report back. We'll see you next week. We'll see you next time. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions
DVD，因为就像特雷弗一样，我觉得它太棒了。我要感谢我在纽约的音响师卡西。我们录制这个播客时，我在纽约，安吉拉在洛杉矶。我和卡西现在可能要出发去吃点那种龙虾冰淇淋了。好的。回来汇报。我们下周见。我们下次再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是Ainsley Bubico。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。有关无广告版本的
of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium，请使用代码 OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。